estas negociaciones quedaron suspendidas
el pasado junio antes de las elecciones
presidenciales en irán para entonces
había optimismo de ambas partes que
pensaban que ya las conversaciones iban
bastante adelantadas y pues se podría
llegar a un acuerdo para retomar ese
acuerdo nuclear que había quedado
destruido prácticamente en el 2018
cuando el ex presidente de donald trump
retiró a eeuu del acuerdo cuando se
conoció que el presidente en irán era el
radical y brian reid y él pidió tres
meses para conformar su nuevo equipo de
negociación que es el que llega hoy a
viena en cabeza del viceministro de
relaciones exteriores ali bagheri cani
que es un hombre ya bastante conocido en
este escenario hizo parte del equipo
negociador durante los tiempos del ex
presidente radical mahmud ahmadineyad
que no logró ningún acuerdo con
occidente como sí lo hizo el presidente
moderado hassan rohan y en el 2015 las
peticiones de irán son como se
consideran aquí por los analistas max
listas ellos piden el levantamiento
total de las sanciones impuestas después
de 2017 tanto las relacionadas con el
acuerdo nuclear como las que no tienen
que ver con él y también vivirán de eeuu
en caso de volver al acuerdo nuclear se
comprometa a que el próximo presidente
no lo destruya lo que es casi imposible
según los analistas pues el presidente
no tiene esa potestad hay que recordar
que eeuu no está sentado en la mesa sino
que está en los corredores de estas
conversaciones y tiene que ser informado
por los otros países que hacen parte de
las negociaciones lo que hace más
difícil llegar a un acuerdo rápidamente